في محطة سيبو شينجوكو المزدحمة في طوكيو،
هناك زيادة مطردة في عدد القطارات،
وفي بعض الأحيان تكون الحاجة إلى الترجمة،
كنت في الواقع متوترًا جدًا عند القدوم
لأنني سمعت أن الناس هنا لا
يتحدثون الإنجليزية، ولا يوجد حل محتمل في
هذه النافذة غير الموصوفة باستخدام
تقنية الترجمة الصوتية، مرحبًا أريد  للذهاب إلى
مستخدمي محطة ماتسوموتو، ما عليك سوى طرح
سؤال بلغتهم الأصلية، وسيظهر
على الشاشة ثم
يُترجم على الفور إلى اللغة اليابانية
ليقرأه الموظفون،
ثم تتم ترجمته مرة أخرى إلى
لغة المستخدم الأصلية، ويخضع
النظام الآن لاختبار التشغيل  طلبت من
المسافرين، بما في ذلك فاطمة هورشر،
تجربة ذلك واعتقدت أن
الترجمة كانت دقيقة للغاية،
وهذا بالضبط ما قلته كان على
الشاشة، كم عدد اللغات التي يمكن لهذا
النظام ترجمة
تقاريرها إلى 12 لغة، وقد تم
إخبارنا بعدد
الزوار الأجانب إليها  تنمو اليابان، حيث تم
تقديم الشاشة حتى يتمكن الموظفون والعملاء من
التواصل بسلاسة وجهًا لوجه،
وهناك بالتأكيد تطبيقات لهاتفك
يمكنها الترجمة ولكن هذا النظام
متزامن ووجهًا لوجه
وحقيقة أنه كان في نفس الوقت
حقيقة أنه  لقد فهمت حقًا ما كنت
أقوله،
على الرغم من أن النظام ليس مثاليًا دائمًا، تعمل
هذه التكنولوجيا على تحسين
البحث بسرعة في مجال
معالجة اللغة الطبيعية
ويتقدم الذكاء الاصطناعي بسرعة كبيرة،
لذا فإن هذه الأنظمة تتحسن
وأفضل وآمل أن تكون كذلك  تُستخدم
ليس فقط في المحطات ولكن أيضًا في
أماكن أخرى في المستقبل، وتأمل الشركة المصنعة
للوحة أن تشمل
الأحداث الرياضية والمستشفيات في المطارات
كجزء من جهد للتأكد من
فهم الجميع بغض النظر عن اللغة التي
يتحدثون بها.
مارك ستيوارت سي إن إن طوكيو